wow holy moly i now have four acms and
two cmas just in the last year and a
half and that's just like
really mind-blowing
[Music]
i hang every single thing that i get and
my dad he walks in my house and he's
like this is a lot and i'm like you know
what dad i have worked my entire life
and when somebody walks in my house they
have to look at it and recognize it you
walk in my living room and if i've ever
had like an issue with having to call
the fire department or whatever they'll
come in and they're just like you know
they're looking at me and they're trying
to figure it out be like it's my sister
it's fine
hey next girl
you don't know me by the way do you have
room for one more um yeah i would love
to have another one yeah yeah well i i
think we've got one for you oh my gosh i
just want to say because like on behalf
of our friends at big machine canada
this is your certified platinum wow yeah
certified platinum for next girl that is
so awesome
yes carly performed those platinum hits
night after night on the 29 tour in
support of her most recent album but the
show was missing a key member her puppy
june i got her during quarantine and i
think that she
fed off of my
really intense emotions during that time
so she's a little anxious she does not
love traveling so she stays with
gami and gampal
along with her brother johnny my parents
actually adopted her her blood brother
but i'm hopeful when she gets a little
older and i have my own bus and i'm not
with my entire crew and van that maybe
she can come she's got to get her own
room she honestly is a little bit of a
diva i think like you know she came into
my life when things were really going
well and awards were coming and i think
she has a big head i think she said i'm
not sharing a bus so when you get your
own bus call me that's it i love it
[Music]